Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein ganz besonderes Video!
Es ist für mich und für Hamza total besonders,
denn es startet wieder meine Ramadan-Reihe. Mittlerweile im vierten Jahr!
Ist das zu fassen? Die vierte Ramadan-Reihe, angefangen vor 4 Jahren.
Generell haben wir glaube ich auch vor 4 Jahren angefangen mit YouTube.
(H: M-hm, da hast du auch die Hände gezeigt!)
Da hab ich nur die Hände gezeigt, das ist so krass!
(H: Da war die Kiki noch ganz, ganz schüchtern!)
Schüchtern, ja das stimmt!
Und jetzt spreche ich zu euch face to face quasi!
Und ich möchte heute mit der Ramadan Reihe starten mit einem DIY,
sonst haben wir auch immer gequatscht im ersten Video und das können wir jetzt auch machen.
So ganz locker, ich zeig euch, wie ihr einen Ramadan Kalender machen könnt
und nebenbei wird noch ein bisschen gequatscht.
Die Idee ist folgende: Wir nehmen uns jetzt etwas -
ich hab erstmal überlegt, einen Kleiderbügel, dann dachte ich mir:
"Nee, sieht nicht so schön aus!"
Ihr könntet es aber nehmen, das ist auch kein Problem,
könntet's dann schön verkleiden mit Blumen z.B. und 'ner Heißklebepistole.
Der Hamza - und da bin ich richtig stolz auf dich, dass du das gekauft hast! -
der hat vor einem Jahr das hier gekauft. Also der hat's mir per Whatsapp geschickt, ne?
Du warst glaub ich in der Stadt und meintest: "Soll ich das mitnehmen?"
(H: Ne, ich wollte dir eigentlich einen Ring kaufen.)
Achso!
(H: Und dann hab ich diesen Ring gefunden!)
Ja, ist ja, passt ja fast so an die Hand!
(H: *kichert*)
Auf jeden Fall hatte er's gekauft, ich muss ehrlich zugeben:
Auf Whatsapp sah es schön aus, als er mir das rübergeschickt hat
und gefragt hat, ob er's holen soll und seitdem liegt's einfach nur im Schrank rum!
Und jetzt hab ich mir gedacht: "Per-fekt!"
Das findet ihr eigentlich fast überall. Also lauft mal echt durch die Stadt -
obwohl, aktuell Corona-Phase, ist ein bisschen schwierig...
Aber vielleicht habt ihr auch jemanden, der sowas daheim hat.
Ansonsten nehmt gern einen Kleiderbügel
und das möchte ich jetzt trotzdem noch ein bisschen verschönern.
Hier sind zwar schon Blumen dran, ihr könntet auch noch weitere Blumen drankleben
mit einer Heißklebepistole.
Aber ich mach das jetzt so, dass hier ein Halbmond drankommt.
So und das schneiden wir jetzt als allererstes aus.
So, falls ihr auch Probleme habt, irgendwie einen Halbmond zu zeichnen,
nehmt euch einfach 2 Tortenringe, 2 Schüsseln...irgendwas, was ihr da habt.
(H: Ich glaub die wenigsten haben 2 Tortenringe zuhause!)
Ja, das macht ja nichts! Man kann auch 2 Schüsseln nehmen oder Deckel von irgendwas.
Und dann einfach einzeichnen und dann kann man sich das ganz einfach ausschneiden.
Ich hab's schon vorbereitet. Genau, so sieht's dann aus!
Und ich find's total ästhetisch.
Also kann man nix sagen, oder Hamza?
(H: Perfekt!)
So, jetzt schnappt ihr euch hier dieses Klebezeug, ihr könnt auch doppelseitiges Klebeband nehmen
oder z.B. Heißkleber.
(H: Ich glaube das ist von Patfix oder Patafix oder so?)
Genau, irgendwie so! Ich hab den Namen jetzt auch nicht mehr im Kopf
aber jetzt drücke ich das einfach dran und fertig...was sagt ihr?
Ich find's süß, was sagst du?
(H: Ich find's schick!)
Schön, also ich find's süß. Warum -
(H: Da fehlt ja noch was!)
Ja, das kommt ja noch alles! Aber vorab: Warum immer die Mondsichel?
Das ist vielleicht auch nochmal ein ganz interessantes Thema für die Nicht-Muslime unter uns.
Ihr wisst ja, die Ramadan Reihe ist für jeden, ich hab erst vorgestern noch ne Nachricht bekommen von Ramona
dass sie sagt: "Ich bin Christin und freue mich wahnsinnig auf deine Ramadan Reihe!"
weil sie die orientalischen Rezepte immer mag!
Aber zurück zur Mondsichel! Warum immer das Symbol?
Es liegt einfach daran, dass man im Islam nach dem Mondkalender geht
und der Ramadan, das ist der Name des neunten Monats.
Und wenn die Mondsichel gesichtet wird, dann beginnen wir zu fasten.
Und dann vergehen 29 oder je nachdem 30 Tage und wenn sie dann erneut gesichtet wird,
dann gibt es das - ja, man sagt "Zuckerfest".
Mir gefällt das Wort nicht so, es hat sich irgendwann mal eingebürgert ne?
Ich glaub weil man den Kindern..
(H: Eingedeutscht!)
Ja irgendwie, ne? Oder weil man den Kindern immer Zucker gibt.
Aber eigentlich ist es im Türkischen z.B. Ramazan Bayramı.
Bayram, das kennt ihr alle! Oder im Arabischen?
(H: Eid al Fitr!)
Eid al Fitr, ich kann das nicht so gut aussprechen wie du
aber genau, so sieht's aus!
Und jetzt fehlen ja noch die "Türchen", die "Päckchen" die 30 Stück
und die machen wir jetzt auch ganz einfach.
(H: Oder auch 29!)
Oder auch 29, das ist ja immer sehr überraschend!
So und jetzt hole ich mir alles und zeige euch dann, wie ich das mache.
(H: Ich hoffe 29!)
Ja, ich auch!
So, jetzt nehme ich mir hier solche Tüten,
die könntet ihr auch kürzer schneiden damit sie vielleicht kleiner sind.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was ihr verschenken möchtet, es kommt auch immer drauf an:
"Wie alt ist das Kind?"oder "Wie alt ist der Erwachsene?",
das ist ja auch eine schöne Idee für Erwachsene.
Ich werd's so machen, dass ich's Hamzas kleinen Schwester schenke.
(H: Ich hab mich schon gefreut, ich dachte der wäre für mich!)
Nein, nicht für dich! Aber Amira wenn du das siehst, kannst du dich schonmal freuen!
Das bringen wir dir auf jeden Fall morgen vorbei
aber den Inhalt verrate ich hier noch nicht damit sie es nicht sieht.
Aber ich hab hier so ein paar Beispiele.
Zum Beispiel was immer geht: Schokolade
oder Selbstgebackenes, da müsst ihr nur darauf achten -
(H: Warum gibt's da keine Datteln mit Schokolade?)
Datteln mit Schokolade? Die isst man einfach so!
Die müsst ihr jetzt nicht hier rein tun. Aber ihr müsst halt drauf achten,
dass die Tüten auch lebensmittelecht sind, ne? Wenn ihr sowas macht.
Eine Handcreme, ne kleine süße oder Kerzen.
Also für meine Schwägerin wäre das jetzt - "Schwägerin", das hört sich so alt an!
Wie alt ist die Amira jetzt?
(H: Ich glaub die ist 13, weiß es aber nicht so genau!)
13, genau! Bietet sich halt gut an. Es kommt immer drauf an, wer es ist.
Ihr wisst es am allerbesten. Wir machen uns das jetzt einfach und nehmen uns so eine Tüte und dann...
ich leg da jetzt z.B. hier diese Schokolade rein.
Und dann machen wir die zu und schnappen uns eine Klammer.
Wichtig ist -
(H: Ich glaub bei dem Beispiel kann man jetzt sagen:
"Ok das kann ich jetzt kürzer schneiden weil da eh nicht viel drin ist!")
Richtig, genau.
(H: Dann hat man halt weniger...)
Genau, da hast du recht. Das könnte man auf jeden Fall kürzer schneiden.
Dann nehmt ihr euch so eine Klammer mit Loch. Achtet darauf,  dass die vorne so ein kleines Loch hat.
Und dann nehmen wir uns ganz einfach von diesem
(H: Kordel?)
Genau, von dieser Kordel/Baumwollschnur und schieben die einfach da durch
Und das machen wir jetzt 29 oder 30 mal!
Ta-da!
Erstes Türchen ist fertig!  Jetzt muss ich mir noch überlegen, was ich in die anderen...
(H: Türchen? Tütchen!)
Erstes Tütchen ist fertig, stimmt!
Und ihr könnt jetzt auch beschriften wenn ihr möchtet, dass z.B. der Beschenkte das immer
an einem bestimmten Tag aufmacht. Oder ich mach das so:
Ich mach 29 mal (ich gehe auf Nummer sicher!)
Ich mach 29 Mal eine Kleinigkeit rein und im 30.  Türchen dann kommt was Besonderes
und das markiere ich dann einfach mit einem Sternchen oben drauf.
(H: Dann ist das dieses Eid Geschenk oder dieses Bayram Geschenk?)
Genau, das ist das Bayram Geschenk. Da kommt dann natürlich was besonderes rein, ne?
Genau, so machen wir's!
Uns ist grad die Idee gekommen - weil das doch so süß aussieht mit dem Sternchen -
dass wir jetzt einfach überall ein Sternchen dran machen und dann doch die Zahlen drauf schreiben.
(H: Meine Idee!)
Hamza's Idee!
Ta-da! Fertig ist der selfmade Ramadan Kalender!
Ich finde ihn richtig, richtig schön! Also mir gefällt der sehr gut!
Ich würde mich auch sehr freuen über so ein Exemplar,
nur leider macht mir das niemand.
Aber ist nicht schlimm!
*demonstratives Räuspern* Ähm ja!
(H: Ich würd nichtmal einen hinbekommen!)
Nein, das ist echt easy, es ist schnell, es ist auch günstig.
Also macht's gerne nach!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Freude beim Nachmachen, viel Freude bei unserer Ramadan Reihe,
euch erwarten orientalische Rezepte rund um den Globus!
Nicht nur türkisch, nicht nur arabisch! Wir machen was albanisches...
ach ich verrat einfach nicht zu viel!
Ihr könnt euch dann einfach überraschen lassen
und dann könnt ihr euch auch gerne die anderen Einführungsvideos von den letzten Jahren angucken.
Da haben wir auch ein bisschen mehr -
(H: Können wir auch einblenden lassen!)
Ja, also heute hab ich jetzt nicht so viel über -
ja, über tieferes gesprochen, das habe ich bei den anderen Malen gemacht.
Heute sollte es einfach nur ein hübsches DIY werden.
Und ich freue mich, wenn ihr zahlreich einschaltet.
Teilt fleißig, erzählt's euren Schwestern, Brüdern, Tanten, Onkels - allen, die ihr kennt!
Verbeitet die Nachricht: "Kikis Ramadan Reihe ist wieder da!"
und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüss, eure Kiki! Und der Hamza!